purpose is a stable and generalized
intention to accomplish something that
is at the same time meaningful to the
self and consequential for the world
Beyond when you have a really strong
purpose how does that help you during
bad times purpose doesn't give us the
answers but it allows us to think in
some kind of programmatic and systematic
intentional way people with purpose not
only are more satisfied and engaged at
work they have better health outcomes
they are less likely to get sick having
purpose is good for us what's your
purpose
all right guys bang bang uh I'm very
excited about this conversation I
thought a great place to start is uh
this idea of purpose uh when most people
hear that you'll get some portion of the
population is gonna cringe up they're
gonna say oh purpose I don't that's not
for me that's that's not my thing I want
to talk about profit so I want to talk
about uh something else talk a little
bit about your evaluation of the state
of purpose in kind of the public
discourse before you actually began to
interview people write the book and
eventually start the podcast
so look honestly uh I was a purpose
skeptic if you told me five years ago
gulati I have a crystal ball and you my
friend are gonna write a book about
purpose I would have said you're crazy
not a chance zero not a chance I'm gonna
and yet here I am uh and I think it's
important to understand how I came to
that realization you know because for me
also I was confused people said purpose
on the one side people saying a purpose
of business is shareholder value and the
other people saying no purpose is
anything but shareholder value some said
it's left wing some said it's right wing
it was just confusion around purposes
attacks on business personal purpose is
a very individual idea
right it starts at the individual level
and there's thousands of definitions for
thousands of people have contemplated
the purpose of human life and I think
one of the best definitions I liked was
William Damon a Stanford psychologist
who says purpose is a stable and
generalized intention to accomplish
something that is at the same time
meaningful to the self and consequential
for the world beyond the self
so meaningful to the self and
consequential for the world beyond the
cell and I think it's important to
understand that that all of us deep down
inside some of us haven't thought about
it we're really too busy saying I don't
have time for this and I'm going to wait
for a while till I contemplate my
purpose in life but I think it's never
too early to think about your purpose
and it's about really saying what do I
want to do that gives me meaning and I
believe all of us deep down somewhere
want to do something that is
consequential beyond the self
whatever that self beyond the self might
be it could be your family it could be
your religious community it could be
your church could be your neighborhood
could be anything
and that's what gives us purpose and I
came to realize that purpose can really
unlock human beings
but purpose can also unlock
organizations
and that to me was the starting point
into my journey that purpose is good for
us it's good for us individually it's
good for us in organizations
what's fascinating about this is as I'm
hearing you kind of describe your
journey in some of the things that you
begin to understand
um everything from military leadership
schools to sports teams uh to even
startups right where there is some big
challenge that is laid out in front of
them a lot of times people will talk
about the idea of leadership being the
ability to bring together a group of
strangers and get them to accomplish
something that they might not have
otherwise accomplished and really it
sounds like your description of purpose
and my understanding in Prior
descriptions of leadership they go hand
in hand right the the good leader lays
out a strong purpose and then the group
the team the company whatever rallies
around whatever that purpose is and
that's kind of what creates a special
situation is is that a fair way to kind
of categorize this
that's a great way to characterize it I
think is that it's interesting uh one of
the coaches I interviewed was Pete
Carroll from the Seattle Seahawks and
Pete said the following to me he said
there's magic when organizations can
inspire people to align their own
personal passion
self-understanding and desire for growth
with a common organizational ambition
it's about cutting people to connect
their own personal ambition and beliefs
with some collective organizational
beliefs if you look at the Marine Corps
another organization I've been looking
at sent perfectums you know I buy into
some collective vision of Who We Are and
I think it's important to understand
where this comes from and why it
energizes employees I'm going to talk
about customers and communities and a
little bit
but why does it energize employees I
think it's important to understand that
you know if you look at human motivation
what how do we show up to work
the basic level starting point is work
as a job right I do it for money it's a
transaction
you go a little higher than that and
then there was this work on what was
called job satisfaction
I do work where I feel satisfied when I
feel I'm being rewarded fairly it's safe
no excess bureaucracy I get the tools
and resources I need and there's pay for
performance reinforcement if I work hard
I get paid well right so that's job
satisfaction
then along comes some researchers in the
70s who say no no there's a higher level
at which you can get people to show up
that's engagement
and engagement people are when they feed
part of a team they have some autonomy
they get to exercise some discretion
it's a positive culture and suddenly
what became important was job design to
make work interesting and interesting so
that people feel engaged and we started
measuring engagement
there's a third level people started
talking about in the last five seven
years which is inspired
inspiration I get meaning out of what I
do what I do I believe makes a
difference in some way in the world
around me and you can see that in
startups as you said earlier you can see
that large companies as you can see
earlier and by this way when I feel that
what I do makes a difference I show up
to work inspire
by the way inspired workers are more
than twice as productive as satisfied
workers
so how do I create a context in which
people are inspired to show up to work
it's a situation where startups I think
are uh such a great example because by
definition a startup is nothing that is
trying to become something and the odds
are stacked against it uh and usually
it's not just can we figure out what's
in front of us but it's also we have to
compete with somebody who has more
resources more time in the market uh
kind of all these uh it seeming
advantages now for those people who
spend a lot of time in the startup World
they see some of those things maybe are
disadvantages and they try to use them
against them uh but you've looked at
sports you've looked at large companies
you've looked at Founders investors like
you've talked to so many different
people around this or there are a couple
of key components to every Mission or
purpose that you see being repeated over
and over again across these
organizations that really kind of
resonates and allows for leaders to say
to their employees their team uh or
their colleagues hey this is where we're
going and gets them excited and inspired
like you're mentioning that's a great
question uh the first thing I do I want
to share with you a precursor to this
book that I wrote called Deep purpose
was an article I wrote in Harvard
Business Review called the soul of a
startup
and I went and interviewed a whole bunch
of startup CEOs I have to admit I had a
biased sample I looked at the ones that
actually make it not the ones that
failed
and you know what I found was
interesting was
everyone thinks that startup is based on
a great idea a big idea and yes almost
all of them especially when I'm
successful have a big idea
but I found that behind the idea was a
grand ideal
we want to change the way this thing
works we want to change the market
exactly what you were saying earlier
it's not the ambition is defined not
just by an idea I have a new widget that
nobody has how to make no I want to
change the way this entire Market
operates and the way customers Buy sell
transact you know that's Airbnb that's
Uber I want to change the marketplace
completely
so I came to realize that there was that
piece of it that the successful startups
actually understand this now let's get
to the definition of purpose I think
you're that was a great question you
asked so let me try to articulate that
for you
I want to first start my purpose is not
a purpose statement it's not like some
mission statement only oh yeah it's the
mission statement purpose is bigger than
a mission statement because it's the
mission is just a simple a set of words
to capture that I intent behind those uh
the purpose itself it's just a
verbalization
what purpose is is kind of understanding
for yourself
it's a unifying idea of the problems you
want to solve
in the world
profitably solved I should clarify so
you're asking yourself
what value are we going to create
who are we going to create it for
customers employees shareholders
Community whatever
and and how are you going to do it
now if you think about this behind this
simple idea it's about business folks
purpose is not about I want to save the
planet only and I don't care about
shareholders purpose is about making a
viable successful business in the long
term
so purpose has ambition goals
but purpose also has in it duties
responsibilities that you know we are a
responsible entity we care about our
customers we really care about our
employees we really care about the
communities where we operate because
it's a long-term business any business
that is trying to be successful not just
in the short term but also long term
cares about these different stakeholders
so we're not here to save the planet
we're here to build a profitable Venture
but as a long-term Venture we have to
think about all the different
stakeholders that impact our long-term
success
what you're really hitting on here and I
think it's so unique I've talked to a
lot of Founders and you these Founders
are sometimes early stage some of them
are series C D E and kind of getting
ready for public markets but in those
conversations uh
the thing that I believe most of them
have learned and I'm paraphrasing a lot
of different conversations into kind of
one key takeaway is that if you don't
have a crystal clear purpose or Mission
that you can clearly articulate to your
employees it creates a scenario where
there's a vacuum of purpose and then
what happens is some of the employees
want this to be the purpose or they
believe this is why they're here or
other employees believe this or or
whatever
and so I've seen them all do it
different ways but when it appears they
all have done is as there's been noise
about a bunch of different purposes the
really good ones have said no we have
One Singular crystal clear purpose and
it is X and each company is different
for why they want to be there or
whatever and what it's done is it's
almost served as a great recruiting
mechanism because people who care about
X they show up and say I want to work at
your company
it serves as a great filtering mechanism
because it seems like the people who
aren't interested in X and are actually
interested in y or Z they go find a
company that's you know doing that
but then also it goes back to this
inspiration that you mentioned earlier
is now it's very easy for people to sit
there and say hey if you're here at this
company you must be into X I'm into X
let's go all work towards this together
and so it's not just like purpose as
like a kind of a a flimsy thing that
kind of floats in the air to your point
it's like no it's a super Crystal Clear
thing that like we really really mean
and it almost makes the organization uh
better because it gets better people it
weeds out the people who aren't there
for the purpose and then everyone's
inspired to kind of work towards it and
so I see this in practice and it sounds
like that's exactly what you're laying
out here is that you have data from
these conversations and interviews
that's highlighting the organizations
are better once you have that Crystal
Clear uh purpose
so extremely well said and your
intuition is spot on
um so for the book I you know I
interviewed uh companies small companies
that used to be smaller at least Etsy uh
company called levongo that was acquired
by teledoc after it went public
um I looked at Gotham green uh which
makes you know salads and herbs that are
sold in Whole Foods and grocery stores
and I but I'll tell you where it really
came through to me was after the book I
was like okay now what and I then I said
okay I've got to go find some other
leaders that are really living some of
these ideas that I try to articulate in
the book and I've just finished a
podcast and one of the uh people I
interviewed was David Velez the founder
of new bank it's the largest digital
Bank in the world starting out of Latin
America
uh another one and you know he had a
very Clear Vision
I want to simplify Banking and I want to
make banking more inclusive for all
now that was the purpose of the business
right and by the way we're not trying to
this charity another thing I've woven
into that but that became kind of the
the marching if you will The Guiding
Light the North Star uh another one was
start uh looked at Kareem which is owned
by Uber now but it's the largest ride
sharing company in all of the Middle
East and North Africa and now that whole
region
and they started with a very simple idea
and they wanted to make right
accessible to people who otherwise can't
get access in socially conservative
societies where women were not allowed
to drive with a stranger how are you
going to make that possible
how are we gonna because without a
driver they can't immobilize they can't
they're not allowed to drive themselves
and they aren't allowed to drive with a
stranger so how are we going to unlock
possibility for them and that how you're
going to make life better for the
drivers who they call captains so that
was Kareem story that you know we are
here to unlock value in a profound way
for people I look at Mom's word Mona
attire the file and so these are all
conversations I've had in this series of
podcasts coming out where monar talks
about how she started mum's World which
is an online platform for mothers young
mothers in the Middle East
so you know you start to see Founders in
different parts of the world who really
those successful ones start with as you
said an ideal and the ideal does four
things I said let me clarify those to
you as well the first you clarified very
clearly is directional it creates
directional Clarity for everybody in
that organization but aligned we know
what we're doing why we're doing it
where we're going the second one is
motivational it gets employees all
excited and inspired around this
ambition vision
the third one is reputational it's good
for brand customers seem to trust
companies that have a purpose
and the last one is the one that we
haven't discussed so far that I hadn't
thought of either was relational in a
world of ecosystems and platforms where
companies are trying to collaborate with
others
companies with purpose are seen as
transparent trustworthy I know where
you're coming from so I feel a natural
Affinity to want to work with you so
there are four benefits if I may say
of purpose that I think small companies
of some of them at least have understood
very clearly and so have many large
companies
so when you see this around these four
things are there companies that can pick
a purpose and actually mess up the
business so whether that is uh they
picked the wrong purpose for the team
they have or the opportunity set or
something like that or they pick a
purpose and then somehow don't execute I
guess correctly against it like how do
you think about maybe the the mistakes
that could occur if somebody's going
through the process of picking a purpose
great question the first thing companies
do wrong is they'll engage in what I
would call purpose washing they create a
purpose to just kind of give themselves
cover
Sarah knows had a purpose when they were
going to be accused of fraud right but
you Pharmaceuticals that is responsible
for the opioid epidemic their purpose
was compassion for patience and
excellence in science inspired a pursuit
of new medicine
so that's the biggest mistake you can
make is like you know trying to engage
in what you might call superficial
purpose or convenient purpose
I think the point we need to understand
about purposes purpose is a forcing
mechanism to ask yourself what business
do we want to be
because to answer that question you have
to really debate and discuss now having
said that could you get the answer wrong
yes
but then you periodically revisit your
purpose you don't do it every six months
but I think is that if you really
thought about it and you give it a
chance to really run it of course and
drive it in the organization in a
serious substantial way
but you know if you look at you know
Microsoft's purpose Microsoft has
evolved its purpose as the market
conditions changed and I can just tell
you for instance it used to be in the
80s it was to put a computer on every
desk and in every home
on the bomber when it didn't do very
well it was to create a family of
devices and services for individuals and
businesses that Empower people around
the globe at home or work and the goal
for the activities they value the most
you can see why that didn't work
right and now is to empower every person
and every organization on the planet to
achieve more
Best Buy has evolved its purpose Johnson
and Johnson with one of the oldest kind
of purpose statements The Credo has also
evolved its purpose so we call it kind
of modernizing or doing a Refresh on
your topic Lego did it so there's so
many examples of companies that have
been around for a while that will do a
periodic refresh
when you have a really strong purpose
how does that help you during bad times
and I think a lot about uh being
inspired everyone always thinks of well
of course that you're more productive
you work harder you you get the the goal
right you accomplish more
but it also feels like during bad times
having a strong purpose may keep you
around or it may allow you to kind of
get you know punched in the face a
couple times and not quit was there
anything that came up in your interviews
and kind of the creation of the book
that uh that really highlighted this
today's episode is brought to you by
ftxus they're a safe regulated way to
buy Bitcoin and cryptocurrencies they've
got very cheap fees sometimes as much as
85 percent cheaper than their
competitors there's also no minimum fees
there's no withdrawal fees or any other
hidden fees ultimately FTX us is trying
to make it dead simple for you to buy
Bitcoin and cryptocurrencies they also
now have digital stock trading as well
with no transaction fees and no payment
for order flow all you have to do is go
download the FTX app today from the App
Store and use code pop and you'll get
some money back every single time you
trade 10 or more again Go download the
FTX app today use code Pomp and every
time you trade 10 or more they'll go
ahead and they'll give you some crypto
back the more you trade the more you
earn download the FTX app today so
that's a great question and I think
given that where we are right now in the
economy with economic headwinds it's a
fair question to be asking ourselves
right
so the first thing I did I wanted to
share with you I did a 2010 study but I
looked at companies during down markets
and every single recession since 2000
and since 19 1945
and what I found was that there are nine
percent of companies that actually use
down times to get ahead
so never waste a good crisis never waste
a good recession if you want to call it
that so what do we need to understand
about these companies that do this well
now I won't bug you bore you with that
study that was published in 2010 in the
Harvard Business review
but I think the point I want to make
over here is as far as purpose is
concerned purpose is not the only answer
for down markets so I want to be very
clear about that
but
what purpose you know when you're in
down markets you are forced to make very
difficult trade-offs
very difficult trade-offs choices
where are we going to contract
where are we going to expand
and that's a very hard decision how do
you take from Peter and give to Paul
and say I'm going to cut here but I'm
going to expand here
the easy answer is the cheese slicer
everybody give me 10 equal equal pain
spread across and that's a that's a
recipe for nothing that's the reason for
mediocrity
those nine percent of companies
understand how to do that and purpose is
a wonderful filtering system
I just talked to somebody this morning
who was the CEO of a company in Europe
and he said you know we are bracing for
one of the worst Winters ahead we're
going to have you know energy Cuts we're
gonna have to shut down our plants we're
gonna have to you know send people home
and we've got to make payroll and we're
gonna have customers who won't have
money to pay us
we are ready for some really really
difficult months ahead
and the question is can purpose help
no
I'm not saying it's going to give you
the purpose doesn't give us the answers
but it allows us to think in some kind
of programmatic and systematic
intentional way about how to consider
those trade-offs
so I actually think that and by the way
if you really use your purpose in these
down markets it's a crucible moment
people will not forget
it will if you're looking for a way to
really bake your purpose into your DNA
nothing like a down Market where you
lean into your purpose invoke and remind
everybody about why you're doing what
you're doing and how that has been
shaped by your purpose
so
nothing like a good crisis never waste
one it returns to this idea of like
tough times make tough people right and
the tough people end up being very loyal
to each other and they kind of went
through the [ __ ] together and come out
on the other side stronger but it does
go back to whether it's good times or
bad times the communication of the
purpose so I almost think of this as you
have to select a purpose usually that is
done by the leadership of an
organization it may be in collaboration
with people within the org or maybe not
but there is a purpose that is selected
did you see any best practices or
mistakes in terms of how to actually
communicate this and I jump to a couple
of data points that just kind of come to
the top of my mind I worked at Facebook
for a few years and there was not
necessarily one single purpose that was
plastered on all of the walls but there
were these kind of underlying ethos
right move fast and break things uh uh
that were all over the wall so it kind
of reinforced it almost implicitly which
then went up to the the overall purpose
of the business which was to connect
every person in the world I also think
about the reinforcement of maybe at an
all hands meeting or in weekly
Communications with the team just
constantly reminding people what were
the best practices there and maybe even
mistakes that you uncovered in terms of
how people communicate the purpose to
their organizations
another really great question
um you know I think is the mistake we
make is we think of purpose is a change
management exercise
you know okay uh tell everyone you know
describe the change communicate the
change break it down into small steps
get uh you know Coalition on board show
some short-term wins
it's not a change this is a more
fundamental exercise about who are we
and why do we exist and I don't think
it's you know putting the purpose
statement out there and Plastering it on
the walls and emails ain't gonna do it
either
I mean purpose has to connect to people
at an emotional level not only
intellectual mode
it's not only an intellectual exercise
you're going to connect it to and then
that's why I think telling it as a
powerful story
connecting it to our past
who are we where have we come from in
the Lego case the Lego founder actually
the Lego CEO went back and understood
the Founder's Journey what were they
doing in 1930s to create this company
like what was the intent what was
intelligent play the idea that you know
playfulness can also have some cerebral
effects as well how do we think about
intelligent play and what does that
really mean but at the same time looking
forward this is not a recreating of the
past so how do we learn to be both
looking backwards while looking forward
how do we have a forward-looking spin on
purpose that is grounded in our Who We
Are you know some companies talk about
detecting their purpose not discovering
their purpose
right and then once you have it how do
you communicate it you know at Pepsi
another company you know Indra Nui
talked about purpose in very personal
terms saying let me tell you about my
personal life story
here's where I grew up my family had
four buckets which they could fill at
four a.m every morning when the water
came for 15 minutes and so I understand
what it means not to have water you know
I know what water shortages are really
like and here is why I think Pepsi needs
to think about water conservation so she
was willing to go there so and then
that's not the CEO other levels down so
how do we communicate the CMO of Pepsi
at the time uh Frank Cooper described it
to me he said you know what it was
complete Surround Sound Performance
as you see
who sees organizations and these leaders
who really kind of lean in have a strong
purpose communicate it well
do we also have data that suggests that
those companies end up not just
performing well today but enduring over
the long term like one of the ideas
around purpose is
as the leadership the founder right you
mentioned Lego founder uh they either
retire they pass away I'm guessing that
purpose would be very helpful in keeping
that organization kind of on track but
but I don't know if you have actual uh
kind of research or data that would
suggest that
so I'm smiling because I'm on the hunt
for that right now because it's really
hard to measure company purpose how do
you measure that purpose orientation so
people have tried survey research they
use annual reports and try to create
counts out of that there's a hunt on the
uh on right now to kind of index company
purpose and then try to see if it
correlates in some way to financial
returns
and I'm part of that hunt I would say
right now we only have suggestion
evidence that suggests that
purpose-driven companies
are more innovators are able to drive
more top-line growth
um have better 10-year TSR
um and I think but it's all large sample
Wise It's very suggestive but I can
speak for my 18 companies that I looked
at I could see very clearly how they
used purpose to drive their performance
it was a very connected idea and that's
where I got those four dimensions from
but the Hunt is on and and I think
people are looking for answers is
purpose correlated with ESG
um how does it connect there's so many
of these Concepts out there so I think
uh we will have better data in the years
to come including from me I hope
so on that line
if we see that purpose can transcend
leadership teams at the same company and
it can be persistent even if it is
updated every you know decade or or
whatever
when people are trying to fill
leadership roles
should they be trying to find leaders
that fit the purpose or do they hire
people and then allow them to kind of
change the purpose of the company as the
leadership changes like it's kind of a
chicken and egg question but to some
degree are you constantly over you know
a 50 or 100 Year time frame just looking
for people who embody the purpose and
and that's the way that we see
organizations be successful or does the
purpose maybe kind of vary within some
framework because the leadership changes
and everyone is a little bit different
so you know it's interesting first of
all I want to clarify
uh purpose is a two-step process having
purpose means I want to know what my
intent is
right and then the second step is okay
what's in that intent you know who am I
here to serve and what are who's more
important and how do I see my business
model Etc et cetera et cetera so one is
having intent second one is what's in my
intent and I think it's important to
understand now to your point
I have a whole chapter in my book
and I've also kind of directly
questioned this in in uh in two of my
podcast interviews where I ask
especially strong founder leaders
that how do you think about succession
because purpose gets so woven up in the
Persona of that individual Howard shirts
look at that
poor guy can't retire he keeps leaving
and coming back and leaving and coming
back to Starbucks and every time he
comes back he says Starbucks has lost
its soul
and so you see that happened to Phil
Knight at Nike
so it's not uncommon you saw that at
Google
so it's not in common to see these kind
of Founders struggling to let go
um
and I think we have to ask ourselves how
do you think about succession as Kevin
Johnson the pharmacy of Starbucks said
to me he says my biggest challenge when
I took over was to go from being a
Founder LED organization
to a Founder inspired organization
and this is not easy not to your next
part of your question is
should a leader should you bring in
people who will change the purpose or
will you I think you first of all should
be hiring people who are bought into the
purpose you have today
I think those same leaders who are
bought into the purpose today should be
able to be smart enough to say you know
we need but I think that purpose is a
filter of who you bring in once in a
while you change your purpose and
sometimes you bring in an outsider so
you say oh gotta change that purpose you
know people are too wedded to what we do
we gotta but a lot of times purpose
shifts are not radical this is not like
our purpose of business has changed
completely overnight
right this is not Blackberry going from
a device company to a software company
um so I think is evolution and
revolution in there and being able to
challenge it but it's a it's a fair
question uh I don't think there's any
research on it and I but I will tell you
that founder lead is a hard one
the purpose gets wound up it's like
personality fixation
so
on that
how do you filter in the interview
process to actually know somebody is
aligned with the purpose versus just
feeding you a bunch of nonsense that
sounds good but maybe they don't align
is there anything that you've uncovered
there of you know you're going to hire a
new CEO you're going to hire a new
executive maybe even just the mid-level
manager
how do you know that they actually are
aligned with the purpose versus they're
just a good interviewer
so look you're asking the universally
hard challenge how do you filter and
screen people you're supposed to have
the answers that's why I'm here anyone
will tell you one of the hardest things
we struggle with is hiring yes how do we
filter in people
and I'll tell you I wrote a case on
Netflix not long ago now Netflix is less
about purpose and more about their
culture okay so bring on cultural fit so
what do they do they actually publish
their cultural deck culture deck now
they're called a culture memo they got
rid of PowerPoint so they made a culture
memo but they put it out there for
anybody competitors anybody to see and
they want recruits to have read it
now they're not going to ask you to
mouse off and repeat what's in the
culture memo
but they'll try to suss It Out by asking
you about your life experiences what
have you done
moments you've faced in life so people
always try to get at these values
questions
I think by asking people like tell me
about adversity you've had to deal with
you know tell me about a difficult
moment that came up in your life
um tell me about choices and trade-offs
you've had to make
I but I do think that you know at
Netflix they call it we only hire fully
formed adults now I'm not implying any
kind of what is fully formed or
partially formed that won't go that far
but you know we need to ask ourselves
like
here's the okay let me give you the rub
the rub is going to be you find someone
who's an absolute star performer
the perfect competence capability
experience that you really want
either hiring them or they're already in
your organization but they don't fit the
purpose they don't fit the values they
don't fit the culture what are you going
to do
that's where the rubber hits the road
what is interesting about that is at a
startup uh a smaller company I think it
could be absolutely catastrophic to hire
that person because if you've got 10
people and this is going to be one of
the 10 10 of your employee base right
doesn't fit the culture and values that
might be a pretty big deal
what I see large organizations do is
they still May hire the high performer
or whatever
but to your point I don't know if it's
because they know it's not a culture fit
or they're just not screening or
filtering or asking the questions around
do align with the purpose like it's
actually pretty rare if you think of
these large organizations how many of
them you know if you had to grade I
don't know the S P 500 and you gave a
you know an a to an f grade
I don't know like how many do you think
you'd given a on purpose to
so look I think at one level you might
say like some people in these
organizations might believe that you
know it's a large numbers one person
through
everybody notices
of course
proportion bonuses these are massive
signals of what is expected of us here
we have one of our absolute best cases
at Harvard Business School uh it's
called Rob Parsons at Morgan Stanley and
it's about this guy it's fictional the
the name is disguised but it's really
Morgan Stanley and it's from like 20
plus years ago
he is brought in by his boss to build a
new business they have been struggling
to break into this business and he's
been told if he delivers
he's going to make manager he was
managing directly in a year
and boy does he deliver
he Nails the market they have double
digit share of the entire Market in a
year
25 years ago he's bringing in 60 million
dollars in fees that year alone he is
absolutely a rock star on every
Dimension Unfortunately they started at
360 that year and in the behaviors he's
showing don't fit the culture you know
they haven't got a purpose yet so
there's more of a culture fit story than
a purposeful story but there's noise
around this guy
and so that's where the case stops and
the question is you're the boss who
hired him you promised him promotion in
one year you have to now make a
recommendation as to whether you're
going to recommend and pro promotion or
not
and the classplex
half will say yes I promised him he's
delivering and the other half will say
no way
it's a great case to teach I got to tell
you people Clash a lot and I saw this in
again in these interviews I did you know
the great leaders are very clear about
who they hire Mona attire and Mom's work
said that was a clear filter for her she
said I didn't even talk about their
competency we can teach you competencies
I wanted to know why do you want to join
us what's exciting to you about wanting
to come and work at Mom's world what are
we doing that seems to resonate with who
you are that was the filter
right
and
so versus walk me through your resume
let me do a rundown and this is to
another organization's large company I
mentioned one more I was a long time ago
now this is dated maybe eight ten years
ago I'm sitting next to a pilot on the
plane and he was off duty and he said I
said what are you doing and he was
interviewing for jobs he was from a
regional he was going to National
Carriers
and I said so where do you want to work
and he said oh no question I wish
Southwest gives me a job I said why he
said all my other interviews they were
technical interviews they wanted to ask
me technical questions and I went to
Southwest there were three Pilots there
and all they wanted to talk about was me
and at the end of the interview I
thought I already bombed it so I asked
them I don't want to ask technical
questions they said look we have your
flight records we know you can fly a
plane we want to know if you really fit
us
because only if you fit us will you
really do what we hope you would do
and so
you know I think great organizations
understand that they create the
guardrails the barriers to who they want
to let in
and then who they're going to promote
and reward and how they're going to
reward
yes we need performance please I I just
want to be very clear I am not
anti-performance I'm saying yes we need
to reward returns performance but we
also as we hear you know the late Jack
Welsh used to say performance and
behavior slash values
and I want to be very clear yes
performance but the other dimension was
Behavior slash values and if you're low
on the value of behaviors
as you see leaders who are able to set
these purposes uh clearly articulate
them recruit the right people
how do they talk to shareholders about
the purpose and shareholders and
employees or or colleagues uh hopefully
having signed uh aligned incentives
where if the business does well the
employees will do well and the
shareholders will do well but it is a
different group of people and I'm not
sure other than usually the most
controversial leaders or stocks do we
see people drawing lines in sand and
basically saying you know if your
ex-type of shareholder we don't want you
usually they're they're much uh uh more
politically correct and a little bit
more polished than that but it does feel
like purpose is somewhat of a line
drawing exercise we're here for x and
we're not here for you know other things
do you see anyone doing this well or did
you get anything from your conversations
and interviews with now you know
hundreds of people around shareholder
communication around purpose this
episode is brought to you by eight sleep
good sleep is a game changer and the
eight sleep pod is the best sleep
machine I sleep on it every single night
a great night of sleep allows you to be
healthier be more arrested and have more
energy throughout the day and on the
brand new eight sleep pod 3 you can
sleep as cold as 55 degrees Fahrenheit
or as hot as 110 degrees Fahrenheit
that's the secret of thermoregulation
better sleep better energy get yourself
an eat sleep you can go to eatsleep.com
pump today to go ahead and get 150 off
your order eightsleep.com pump not only
do I sleep on it every night it
literally changed my life and I begged
the founders to let me invest in the
company eightsleep.com go get yourself
an eight sleep pod and get a better
night of sleep excellent question uh let
me start can I flip around on first of
all why do shareholders care about
products okay right and then let's get
to how do you communicate purpose to
shareholders
so
uh let me start now so you know as you
know Larry Fink wrote the forward to my
book and I was inspired by Larry to
actually write this book
but I was puzzled at first like why
would a shareholder or representative of
shareholder care about purpose I then
also talked to
um temasek The Sovereign wealth fund of
Singapore
and I interviewed Dylan pillai the CEO
there
and I came to realize that the vast
majority of investors
are long-term investors of course we
have some short-term investors too who
care about short-term returns but the
vast majority of us our Pension funds
retirement funds you know indexed
indexing out there for the long Horizon
we have a long Horizon into business so
and their take was how do I ask a
business to keep an eye on the prize
and purpose is a way for me to
understand what is your long-term vision
and by the way remember what I said
earlier when any business tries to
imagine their long-term reason for being
they naturally will have to think about
employees customers communities and even
the planet
right so I'm just asking you hey I have
long-term investors I want to share with
them what your long-term vision for your
business is and long-term vision for
anyone encompasses shareholder value of
a customer value Community value
employee value all of them feed into and
reinforce shareholder value actually
so I just want to know what is it that
you really believe in it's a statement
about who are you and why are you as a
business exist what's your unique place
in the world so people have confused
this into like oh investors are forcing
businesses to do ESG and they're really
forcing them to do sustainability and
it's pushing their agenda on to them
they're saying if you're a long-term
business you have to have some ESG
standards because Society is going to
impose them on you
so you better have a perspective on this
because it's becoming mandatory almost
in the world so I as an investor really
care about that
so I think there's a kind of twisting of
this logic that has happened so
investors care keeping in mind long-term
value of a business viability of a
business
now the question becomes how do I
communicate that to shareholders
and I think is you know I think it's the
clearer you are about the choices you're
making I've interviewed a number of CFOs
for this actually
to understand that CFO stole
that how do CFOs present themselves to
the market
and I first I think there's a you're
right about one thing your instincts
were that there's a bit of a matching
that happens in the shareholder Market
what kind of investors do I really want
to have in my you know mix of investors
and clarifying how you're imagining your
business makes it easier to see what
kind of investor pool you're gonna
attract
uh but beyond that you're creating kind
of expectations with investors too like
look we are right now and even when we
do large investment projects we say look
the quarterly returns for the next
several quarters are going to be a
little soft because we are about to
embark on this huge initiative that is
going to double our manufacturing
capacity in Asia and you're gonna see
payback out of that three quarters down
the road
so I think you know purpose is level
setting in some ways with investors as
it is with other stakeholders employees
customers and communities uh I think one
that we don't talk about we we somehow
imagine investors as this kind of
incredibly myopic
only quarter to quarter returns driven
individuals and there are some who are
like that
but there are others who are not
as I hear you talking about the
shareholders and purpose
I think a lot about uh in the crypto
decentralized World whatever they're not
businesses which I think everyone uh um
at least at the moment they're not
viewed that way and don't seem to
operate that way
but what I do find fascinating is that
when something is decentralized it's the
equivalent of a company with no
leadership team right if you took the
CEO the CFO kind of the the the c-suite
out now you and I probably could think
of a million reasons why that would go
horrifically wrong
right without leadership without
hierarchical structure without a uh some
sort of true purpose and and planning
and strategy like that sounds like a
recipe for disaster probably many case
studies inside of your classroom end up
uh being some version of that
but what I do find fascinating is that
if you take something like a Bitcoin
there was a Creator we don't know who it
is but they put purpose or or some sort
of Direction down on paper in the white
paper and they disappear and it's almost
like a Founder kind of retiring or
leaving or whatever
but there hasn't been the reinforcement
and so I always think about like first
of all the idea is big enough in
critical powerful enough right where
people get excited about it without
having kind of all the normal aspects of
a business
but also the purpose was so clear that
it has persisted now it's only been 13
14 years but if it continues the way
it's going it really is this like
powerful clear message
and so the reason why I use that is like
that is succeeding against the odds
right if you're able to take a really
clear powerful message and then you have
a CEO you have a board you have kind of
all the things that we know make
businesses great
it feels like this is almost like a
secret weapon for the businesses that
understand it and and as you've talked
you know kind of through our
conversation it does feel like maybe
companies are waking up to this and
realizing that some did it naturally and
that was their intuition and there
wasn't so much a strategic reason as
much as that's just how they operated
their business but now do you hear and
see Founders or executive teams talking
about this from a strategic stand-up
Point saying hey we've been in business
for 20 30 40 years we don't have a
purpose that is clearly articulated we
need to do it because it is a talent
retention tool it is a you know
advantage in the marketplace it is you
know a b or c reason
or is it no the companies that start out
with a strong purpose or the ones who
keep them but you don't really see
companies Who start out with no or weak
purposes end up being able to transition
into those strong purposes
so let me start with the first part of
your question around uh decentralized
finance and that's a fascinating
question also so I look within our
organization first then we'll talk about
these kind of diffuse entities that are
not even organizations per se
what do organizations do when you you
know as soon as you have 5 10 15 people
coming together even two people coming
together in a household we have a
division of labor problem
who's going to do what ask coordination
right so we want to have collaboration
and coordination of that so you know
who's doing what and what sequence and
how we're going to do this that and the
other
as you get bigger the answer there's a
collaboration problem that kicks in and
the other one is what we call the
consistency problem
right how do we build standards that we
have to repeat and do things in a
consistent way
now
what do we do we build elaborate
organizational structures we build silos
we build kpis we build metrics we do all
this stuff to kind of be able processing
so we call it structures and processes
and culture
structure process culture are the three
kind of controlled systems we use to
regulate the individuals who are in that
small or large organization
right now some would argue that
structure and process stifle law
creativity it bogs us down in
bureaucracy and we resist but we can't
we need silos we need accountability we
need process discipline
now if you believe that process purpose
is another way to regulate Behavior
if you want to call it that
culture is a control system so is
purpose it creates guard rails it
creates guidelines and if it's a deep
purpose and you've internalized it it is
really going to be a Godwin for you
does that then allow you the chance to
loosen your structure and loosen your
processes
and so when I saw was companies that
were you know everyone talks about
empowerment but there's a lot of people
talking about fake empowerment you talk
about it but you don't really do it
right
with purpose possibility I'm not saying
it works always because purpose is not
like people are buying in all the time
you have the possibility to loosen your
structure and processes to create more
real genuine empowerment I wrote a whole
chapter on this Bible
now you've taken it to an interesting
stream of like can you have
confederations of organizations
connected through a purpose or
individuals that are somehow able to
find alignment with each other
and Trust religion
open question
I think possible I don't think there's
enough research for me to definitively
say that you know if only ethereum and
Bitcoin and others kind of articulate a
purpose they're gonna really be able to
create alignment among the disparate
entities and individuals who are
operating and working in those markets I
think it's an idea it's interesting it's
an intriguing thought
I don't really have an answer to that
one but I have I did mention earlier to
you that organization with purpose are
perceived as more transparent and
trustworthy by others which is in the
eyes of the beholder
yeah
I don't know what the answer is either
it is a very unique thing which
obviously I think has come taken the
World by storm
um but when you think of it through this
purpose lens uh it is um yeah it feels
like there there's something there and
it's hard obviously the intuition versus
the data uh will take a long time to to
kind of uh clear out one of the examples
I think I'm personally most fascinated
by is uh the company coinbase which uh I
don't know maybe it was last summer or
so uh the CEO and founder of the
business came out and said look there's
a whole bunch of stuff going on
internally kind of this idea of like the
the lack of clarity around why we're
here and so
um he put together a piece uh and
clearly articulated we are here to do
this and it was really around Financial
Empowerment and kind of why he started
the business
in a couple of takeaways for me were one
it's easy for the founder to do that
because he could say hey I started this
business you know we're almost a decade
later let me remind everyone why I
started this business and and so coming
from him I think was powerful
two I thought it was fascinating he
didn't just send it internally he
published it publicly to your point
but the third thing was he got a lot of
blowback and there was a lot of people
who said not even so much we don't like
your purpose it was we don't like the
fact that you're stating one purpose and
saying we are not here for these other
purposes
and so I think in hindsight a year later
if you were to ask him and I've seen him
on interviews and stuff talk about he's
very happy he kind of took the route
that he did he thinks it was a net
positive for the business
I also think that it takes a special
type of person and a unique business to
do that versus if that had been Disney
or Coca-Cola or you know one of these
businesses who has not founder-led
anymore who had not been around for only
you know a decade or so
how do you think about this
so I I don't know enough about the
coinbase story so I don't want to
comment on that necessarily but I think
there's an interesting idea behind your
question
so one of my colleagues uh you mentioned
Disney uh so one of my colleagues
actually
um once Steve Jobs realized that he was
going to pass away in a finite time
he hired two of my colleagues to come
and start to write cases about Apple
and he wasn't going to do a purpose of
Apple that was not his thing he didn't
want to he didn't believe in one-liners
but he felt it was important to capture
the philosophy the principles that made
Apple who it is
and he thought the best way to do that
is capture historical decisions they
made and the rationale and how they
thought through their decisions so
purpose was going to be inferred through
these key decisions that apple had made
in the past
and there was a story behind that
because Steve had been on the board of
Disney
and what really frustrated about the at
Disney's board meetings was whenever
they had a difficult decision to make
somebody on the board would say let's
think about what Walt would have done if
he was here
and Steve said what is not here he died
decades ago the world has changed why
are we trying to channel world right now
and we need to be thinking forward so
his idea of distilling the Apple secret
sauce
was let's look at some key decisions we
have made over time and I want every
employee to go through this these
discussions of these decisions because
through them they'll understand the
essence of what makes Apple Apple
and when you see that
does it take the type of leader who is
willing to hire your colleagues and say
I know this is special I want to
document this and and kind of is
self-aware enough to realize that not
every corporation uh has the purpose has
the process has kind of the ethos and
and everything makes Apple special
is that the same type of leader that is
needed to actually execute correctly as
well like you need self-awareness to be
able to set the right purpose and and
kind of really drive it home on a
consistent basis with the employees
I think you have to buy into the idea
that this essence of an organization is
key to your competitive advantage it has
to be a priority for you it has to be
and I think Steve only realized that
when he himself saw his own mortality
and said oops I'm going to be gone and
of course Tim is going to do a great job
which he has done but I want to be able
to distill the essence of what makes us
special
and our purpose which I can infer
through these key decisions and moments
will allow people in generations to come
to capture that special element of Apple
it's not a culture document it's not
even a purpose statement it's something
that has to be distilled and inferred
and I want people to remember that and I
think so some leaders understand that
there is an Essence about this what is
the secret sauce
um the founder of Kareem said it's our
superpower
it's really what makes us different and
people he said most businesses don't
seem to realize that he's an ex McKinsey
consultant and he says I never realize
it but now that I've been in it and
built a billion dollar business and
successfully built it and sold it and
I'm still running it
I've come to realize he said from my
experience is our superpower
why did David Velez say that or the
founder of Arco Dorados the largest
franchisee of McDonald's in the world
with over 1500 locations why would he
say that
I found these podcast interviews I did
to be fascinating because a lot of the
founders talked in very eloquent terms
about having this Essence being the
secret sauce and they appreciated it
because they said as we grow bigger
it's naturally easy to lose it
it fades away
one aspect
um that I think is very interesting you
said you've interviewed a lot of sports
uh coaches
and so if you especially think at the
college level and a little bit at the
professional level
inside of a business
you get people that are hired and you
hope that they stay and work with you
for 10 20 years
if you're a college coach I think you
mentioned Pete Carroll uh Nick Saban
folks like that at the college level
every three or four years basically you
have a whole new team right because they
come in they were they're there for
three or four years and they go and
hopefully they'll play at the the next
level or they go and they get regular
jobs and and comes off the team
having a purpose that is able to bridge
between each one of these different
teams because really every year is a
different team but there's a lot of
overlap
feels like a pretty good way to ensure
that you can build some of these
dynasties that these coaches have built
because really that's one of the only
things between the coach and what the
purpose or kind of the mission of the
organization is other than that almost
every year a lot of things change
so look you know the first thing I
learned from these Sports coaches who
are extraordinary individuals by the way
um is that as one of them said to me
Pete said to me he said look
I unlock human potential
right
my job is to take an individual who's
saying I am performing at my best and
take them to a level that they didn't
think they could do
right that's what we do as coaches and I
think college sports is one of the most
extraordinary illustrations of that
where a coach takes a team and gets them
individually and collectively to perform
at a level that they didn't even think
they could do
and it's individually and collectible
right and I think is now you know this
as well as I do people will do a lot for
themselves when their own self-interest
is at stake but if they have a
commitment to a collective
a tribe A family their team
we know that people are willing to do
even more for a collective that they
really buy into than they are for
themselves
right and so what we're trying to do is
help people how do you bind them to the
collective in a way that they feel so
identified with the collector
and purpose is one way to do that it's
also self-awareness what's your purpose
here are you here to just be a great
football player uh and make a lot of
money and join the NFL is that your life
purpose
and that inspires a lot of people to do
a lot right people are willing to do a
lot for pay for performance
but if you remind them that listen you
also can imagine what your individual
purpose is in life
and put money and success in perspective
and hopefully then think about how am I
becoming a better player a better human
being how am I advancing my own whole
self
through my sport
you might show up differently
and I think that's the beauty of what I
think some of these coaches understand
that you know you're not trying to be
naively idealistic here
but you're also trying to say I want to
elevate their thinking and Elevate how
they show up
I mean look at what's happening in the
war in Ukraine folks I mean think about
it
I don't are you telling me that
ukrainians are genetically more
courageous than anybody else
when you are bought into a Cause
you show up differently
you see this for sure during wartime I
think you see it during uh games people
like to celebratize the underdog versus
you know the people who think they're
supposed to win all that type of stuff
um
but also I think at the individual level
and I know that you uh have used purpose
to have more honest conversations with
individuals I know that you think uh the
talk of purpose elicits different types
of responses maybe avoids the CEO speak
talk a little bit about
throughout your career you've talked to
a lot of people right and uh at all the
uh degrees of success
and it seems like this topic
specifically has led you to a different
type of conversation with people that
one you enjoy but also two it seems like
you've learned different things about
certain people that maybe you otherwise
wouldn't if you weren't talking about
purpose
so I have to confess to you this is all
new to me and the way you said it is
exactly right I wrote the book I
interviewed people about their company
purpose and I was like tell me about the
company purpose and how you did it
and then when I started this podcast
series I first started my first
interview like okay tell me about your
company purpose and what did you do and
then I stumbled into asking the question
tell me about your purpose
why are you here tell me how did you
come to realize your own purpose when
did you first start thinking about your
brothers and I have to tell you these
are very I felt very fortunate to be
talking about these very influential
important successful leaders from all
over the world
the conversation shifted
it was a much more I would say authentic
and intimate conversation and I learned
you know every leader there's a story
behind a story
you you can talk to them as CEO of an
important company and what they're doing
for the company
but it's really hard to tap into their
Humanity like who are you really
and this purpose conversation about
their individual purpose before I even
get to their company purpose
led to I would say a very different set
of conversations
and I learned so much about leadership
through these conversations in the
process
what has been the most surprising thing
so you went in you said you were a
skeptic
now you're not a skeptic so that's like
surprise one it's just it seems like you
you're a convert right which uh which is
good but is there anything that outside
of just now I believe that has really
surprised you and and kind of looking
back you're like I can't believe that's
the thing I took away from it
so the first thing I realized was
purpose is good for business
right that's one thing like who's going
to say oh we don't want to have a
purpose
the other thing about purpose is good
for us individually
there's data research showing that
people with purpose not only are more
satisfied and engaged at work they have
healthier Healthcare Better Health
outcomes you know they are less likely
to get sick chronic diseases you know
harder heart attacks stroke dementia
having purpose is good for us I mean
what does it mean not to have a purpose
I don't want to have a purpose
and we then say oh I don't want purposes
only making money and shareholder value
it's like breathing folks we all need to
breathe to live
of course but do we live to breathe
I don't think so
that leads me to my last question which
is like the softball of all what's your
purpose
so I have to tell you you know
I feel very fortunate to be working at
an institution where my my purpose
aligns very closely with the
organization's purpose
we educate leaders who make a difference
in the world
and that very closely summarizes how I
think about my work related purpose
which is we I educate leaders who make a
difference in the world
now remember our life purpose has many
sleeves to it work is one family is
another you know avocations is another
one so for me I feel very fortunate that
my
by my purpose that is related to work
very close I educate leaders who make a
difference in the world hopefully
positive difference in the world
what about your personal purpose
you know I think we uh I I really
believe that my purpose is to be able to
have a positive impact on the
communities and the people I'm
surrounded by
and so what does that mean in terms of
uh as you've done all this work on
purpose how do you actually live that on
a day-to-day basis because I think one
of the pieces is people will listen to
this and they'll say to themselves I get
it purpose is important for business
purpose is important for better life and
kind of the inspiration and all that
stuff how do I take the purpose and
imply and apply it on a day-to-day basis
so the first thing we have to worry
about purpose is an evolving story my
purpose when I was in my early 20s was
different right my purpose when I was a
young parent became different right
suddenly my purpose had changed into my
family my children I have responsibility
for them right my purpose today at this
age and Stage is different
and I look at my own self and I ask
myself like have I made a positive
difference in anything that I've done
today you know where am I through my
research through my teaching through my
interactions you know I think we very
sometimes we focus on value capture
right we all measure like okay what came
in the door today into the bank account
value capture I think I at some point
you start to say I want to focus on
value creation value capture is happens
when you naturally when you're creating
value value capture happens but how am I
creating value
in the environment and the communities
where I operate
um have I had a positive impact in a
meaningful and real way
yeah that that's incredible I love the
idea of uh the interesting value capture
and kind of creating the value I think
it's a very important distinction where
can we send people to uh find the book
or download the podcast as the as they
get excited about listening to these
conversations
so look the easiest place to go is deep
purpose.net which is where I have the
summary there's some videos summarizing
the book and my research
um you can also find me on LinkedIn
there's a newsletter I don't flood my
LinkedIn feed but I periodically every
few weeks will put out something that
relates to my larger interest in
unlocking value
unlocking possibility
and so deep purpose.net or LinkedIn
which is just ranjay gulari my name
um and I want to thank you this has been
a most enlightening conversation you
have pushed me hard in a good way so uh
I appreciate that very much so thank you
I uh uh I'm very interested in I find it
uh absolutely fascinating the way that
you articulate it I think is incredibly
powerful so I hope that everyone who is
watching and listening to this goes and
checks out the book and then looking
forward to many of the conversations you
pretty much had a uh a who's who's list
of people that I'd want to hear on the
purpose side so I'm excited to it's
listen to that as well and thank you for
your time today I think people probably
learned a ton from you
thank you very much thanks for having me